tell me you know could you write down
the name of the rehabilitation clinic
you mentioned as I able say
[Laughter]
well I tried to do some research once
Mo's and I rented a movie about a Latina
wedding planner with a big fat Moe's and
I rented a movie about a Latina wedding
planner with a big fat ass I tried to do
some research once no I know nothing
about wedding planning I tried to do
some research once Mo's and I rented a
movie about a Latino wedding planner
with enormous small well no it's it's
not it's not anybody's fault you know
what let's just look at the lines and
then we'll do the scene again thank you
you are insane right now don't even get
to any of our dialogue great Phyllis did
I or did I not say fruit
you did say fruit and what is that cake
and what did I say
is this something is this something is
this is this funny to you Phyllis she's
nervous yeah well she should be nervous
because I'm about to kick her ass I'm
gonna walk now we all think you're liar
what would a liar bring mini mounds bars
[Laughter]
[Music]
I Stanley
[ __ ] we're gonna need a signal to bolt
out of there at the slightest sign of
danger
okay I'm not signals let your lips in
exam no no no like this
[Music]
tell us come on oh Jesus be all right
Phyllis are you all right are you okay
I think I'm going to need some new pants
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
and this copier is working fine that's
the original well
[Laughter]
we are having an earthquake get it on
the DVD so glad so they well the trains
going through sprinting we just want to
say we're very sorry if you say screw
you one more time whoa okay guys I did
the face you like if you say screw you
one more time if you say screw you one
more time hey guys just cool it
basically dynamics of alright basically
in the workplace oh there's always a
theme idiot about the tickets I know I
don't know
and then you put it on a wheel and spin
it and you make it into the cup and you
glaze it putting the kiln and yeah I
bought that in the Gift Shop though hey
there gorgeous how you doing today good
thank you
how's it hanging listen my name you know
what things uh things I guess aren't
aren't so bad after all
okay you either break off your
engagement with that singing buffoon
apologize and then date me or you can
say goodbye didn't this I think Phyllis
we gave you one hell of a wedding shower
it was a golden shower
Phyllis we all gave you a gone we all
came in this room for your wedding and
gave you a call we all came in here and
gave you a golden shower well where's my
goldish I'm gonna try to get to bed by
8:00 8:00 yeah
move vikrum best salesman I ever met in
my life
what's his last name I want to say mmm
she she poopoo I know that's not it
he worked in the telemarketing place
shoo-shoo new voila
it's not it but you worked at that she
did she did do poo I know that's not it
but he worked at I just I feel like some
of these directions to Schrute farms are
a little weird I mean like 156 paces
from the light red mailbox make a left
walk until you hear the Beehive and make
a right if you are attacked by
territorial oh I have this really these
if you smell bear pee turned the other
way
you